wiggles a year old pup from California
was rescued from the street by animal
control they noticed immediately
something was wrong Wiggins falls
frequently and can't control his bowels
at a local shelter these unusual
symptoms put his chances for adoption
near zero but here at dog town they
consider every animal adoptable now the
challenge for the team find the right
home for this disabled dog boy at dog
towns clinic head veterinarian dr. Mike
Dix evaluates Wiggles for the first time
he must determine if wiggle suffers from
a life-threatening illness or if his
condition is manageable good boy that's
what you walk
he's like a drunken sailor
first impression of Wiggles is is crazy
it's cute and an ugly sort of way and
he's just very endearing Wiggles
symptoms may be the result of bad
breeding technique if he was found
somewhere near like a bulldog breeder
which he kind of does have Bulldog
qualities with his short squatty legs as
under biased service question phase dog
breeders often use inbreeding to
guarantee desirable traits but this
technique limits the gene pool and can
lead to genetic mutations with symptoms
like the ones Wiggles displays he could
be a purebred dog purebred gone awry who
knows dr. Mike's first goal determined
Wiggles condition is neurological he
puts Wiggles through a battery of
diagnostic tests so most dogs let me
flip it over
what return to normal right away
Mike discovers a disconnect between the
nerves and Wiggles foot in his brain
indicating a problem with this
neurological system whether that's a
problem with the brain problem with the
nerves or problem with the pathway
could be something going on with a
cerebellum the cerebellum the part of
the brain which controls balance plays a
vital role in basic motor function menís
him which I kind of pretend like I'm
gonna poke him in the eye he's blinking
quite a bit yes you need a cerebellum
intact to do that
Wiggles blink response indicates a
normal cerebellum Jacobo why a dog like
Wiggles it's actually kind of an
exciting interesting case I figure out
where his problem is I've always been
kind of science minded person wondering
how things work how to fix things the
little intricate processes that are
involved in life a malformed spine might
explain wiggles symptoms an x-ray will
reveal that this is the problem
my handsome
this spine actually looks pretty good
doesn't mean it's not a spinal issue but
there's nothing obvious with a severe
brain or spinal injury ruled out it's
likely Wiggles was born with a genetic
defect that affects his neurological
system but he's stable
so Mike gives the go-ahead for adoption
I think what he has is gonna be a
permanent issue with him but the goal
will be that he can learn to cope with
what he has and adjust accordingly
now Dogtown faces a daunting task find a
family willing to care for Wiggins
disabilities at all finding it home for
a squatty Bulldogs dog that falls over
and occasionally drops poop it's just a
little bit harder to find the right
person for them just takes a little more
time